We're speaking today
with Tom Perez,
the Secretary of Labor
for the United States
Department of Labor.
So thank you, Mr.
Secretary, for joining us.
Oh, it's a pleasure
to be with you.
Maybe you could
talk a little bit
about what's changed
since you and I
entered the labor force
a number of years ago.
I'm thinking about a
good friend of mine
whose dad graduated
high school, went
to work at Bethlehem Steel,
and worked there for 42 years.
And as we fast
forward to today, it
is much less frequent to
see someone at a job for 30,
40 years like our
parents' generation.
And once again, you look in
the world of manufacturing
just to take one example.
The jobs of today are quite
different than the jobs
of yesterday.
And frankly, in many
cases, a high school degree
simply won't suffice.
And so my parents
always taught me
education is the
great equalizer.
It's what made
America a superpower.
This commitment to free public
elementary and secondary
education, and today we need
to keep that investment.
Maybe we could focus on some
of the current challenges
and opportunities.
We're coming out of
this great recession,
the worst since the
Great Depression.
The economy's been growing, but
not everyone is sharing equally
in benefits of the growth.
What accounts for
where we are today?
Well, it's always important
to look at where we were,
where we are, and
where we need to go.
The rising tide of progress
in the late '90s that we saw
lifted more boats.
Today, that rising tide
isn't lifting as many boats
as it needs to.
We need to make sure that
everybody has that chance,
and one of the biggest
challenges in this context
is addressing the issue of
stubbornly stagnant wages.
And that's not
simply a phenomenon
of the great recession.
For decades, productivity
growth and real wage growth
rose hand in hand.
And then starting around
1980, that began to change.
And we see productivity
increases of over 90%
and real wage
growth of 2% or 3%.
And that's unfair to workers.
Workers have helped bake
the pie of prosperity,
but their sweat equity
hasn't translated
into financial equity for them.
And so too many people haven't
gotten a raise in years.
Too many people are
working two, three jobs.
One of the best family
values is the value
of time spent with your
family, and folks just
don't have enough
time to do that.
We could talk a little bit,
perhaps, about how we can get
wages and high quality jobs
moving in the right direction.
And I know you are
an ardent advocate
for the administration--
for the country-- about the
importance of skills and skill
development.
I wonder if you could say
what your thoughts are
on what workers might do and
what kind of opportunities
we need to provide for workers
to keep those skills current so
that people can adapt over time.
You look at the data and
the education dividend
is undeniable.
The more education you have,
the greater the chances
are that you can punch your
ticket to the middle class
and then stay there.
It's important to
recognize that there
are multiple educational
pathways to the middle class.
Some people graduate
high school and go
to college, but other people--
especially when I was growing
up in Buffalo-- a lot of folks
went through the
apprenticeship route.
And that route, if you go
to places like Germany,
has equal stature with
the four-year route.
And here in America,
we've devalued
that over the course
of recent decades.
And that's why this
president, and we
at the Department of Labor,
are trying to change that.
And I've met so many folks who
have completed apprenticeship
programs, whether it's the
traditional skilled trades,
whether it's IT, whether
it's in the health sectors.
These are alternative
pathways to higher ed,
and many of these
folks who complete
apprenticeships then get
an associate's degree
at a community college and
then go to a four-year college.
So it's important
as people think
about that pathway to upscaling
to recognize that there are
multiple entry
points, and they all
lead to core competencies
that enable you to compete
and thrive, not only
in today's economy,
but in tomorrow's economy.
Well, I think your
work on apprenticeships
is so important because
the evidence is so
clear on how well they pay off.
For every dollar we
invest in apprenticeship,
the return is
something like $27.
I wish every investment we
made had that kind of return.
One of the concepts that
we use in this course
is the term social
contract, and you've
been an articulate
proponent of a strong voice
for the American workforce.
I wonder if you could speak
a bit about the role of voice
in our economy, and
what it means to workers
and what it means
to our society.
It's not a coincidence in
my mind that the periods
in our nation's history-- in
the 20th century for instance--
where you had decade after
decade of real wage growth
didn't just coincide but
coexisted with a period of time
where workers had
a collective voice.
Where you had much
higher union density.
Where people could advocate.
America's greatest
generation who
fought in World War II--
millions of them came home,
and what did they do?
They worked
collectively once again
in the workplace to
fight for fair wages.
And what we I think have
lost today is too many
folks have bought into
this false choice of you
either take care
of your shareholder
or you take care of your
worker, but you can't do both.
I categorically reject that,
and it is indeed a false choice.
You look at places
like the Ford Motor
Company, an existential
crisis in the great recession.
And what happened?
The UAW and Ford got
together around a plan
of shared sacrifice leading
to shared prosperity.
So I visited a plant in
Louisville, Kentucky,
that makes the Ford Escape.
And in 2007, they were
down to about 700 workers.
They weren't sure
if they were going
to shutter the plant entirely.
And as a result of
that cooperation,
you see shared sacrifice
leading to shared prosperity.
And today, they're 4,400
employees and growing,
and that doesn't include
the supply chain.
So when the workers have
a voice, America succeeds.
There are many ways to
give voice to workers.
Unions are certainly one way.
There are also a
number of nonprofits
that are working with taxicab
drivers and home health
workers and fast food workers.
Nonprofits that are very
agile, and they're really
standing up for low wage
workers trying to give voice.
There are a lot of
headwinds in this issue.
There are courts
right now that are
hostile to efforts to organize.
There's hostile
state legislatures
right now that are making it
hard for public sector workers
to move forward.
There are well-heeled
multi-billionaires
who are spending a lot of
money trying to muzzle voice.
But these forces
existed 100 years ago.
We've defeated these before.
The arc of the moral
universe has always
bent toward justice
and toward those
who seek to expand opportunity.
But it doesn't bend on its own.
I'm wondering if you
would like to conclude
with your own advice for the
next generation workforce.
First of all, I think education
is the great equalizer.
So you want to make sure that
you have the skills to compete
today and tomorrow.
Secondly, you need
to find your passion.
Happiest is the person whose
job is his or her hobby
because then you never have
to work a day in your life.
Third, you need to reject
these false choices of those
who suggest that if you burn
out your neighbor's candle,
that will make your
candle shine brighter.
That's never been who
we are as a nation.
We've always been a community
recognizing that we all succeed
only when we all succeed.
We rise and fall on the
strength of our middle class
and the strength of our
ladders of opportunity
to the middle class.
And so I want everyone-- all
your students-- to make sure
they understand that
opportunities abound.
And low wages and
no benefits are
a choice that
companies make, not
a necessity born out of
globalization or technology
advances.
These are choices.
And you need to make that choice
as a student to get involved
and to exert leadership.
Well, a very, very powerful
statement, Mr. Secretary.
Thank you for all you
do and for everyone
here at the Department of Labor
does for the current generation
workforce, and for
all of those to come.
Well, it's an honor.
Take care.
Thanks again.